JIM: I've invited a friend
of mine, Brendan Murphy, who
we happened to meet
by chance encounter
on a boat ride in the Caribbean.
And a conversation has
now led to a friendship.
And he was nice enough
to accept an invitation
to come speak to
you today at Google.
So I want to tell you a
little bit about Brendan.
He's a former professional
athlete who's now an artist.
So he's going to tell you a
little bit about his journey
and how that came about.
He's currently in over
500 collections worldwide.
He started and sold an
athletic company called Solfire
that some of you may
have seen or heard about.
And he most recently
launched a brand new venture
called 143 The Love Exchange.
I've always wanted to say that.
I finally got a
chance to say that.
But today, he's
going to take you
on an artistic
journey of discovery
and following one's
intuition-- both the art of it,
and the science of it.
So it's going to be an
interactive session.
And we hope you will
participate as much as possible.
So without further ado, I want
to introduce Brendan Murphy--
today's Google Talk speaker.
BRENDAN MURPHY: Thank you, Jim.
Happy St Patrick's Day.
I brought my own audience just
in case nobody claps or laughs.
So I suggest you
do that whenever
you have to give a speech.
I met Jim as he said--
he already left.
Jim and I-- we met
on a little boat
ride coming from Richard
Branson's island.
Jim left that part out.
We were at a charity function.
He's been a
fantastic new friend,
and a lot of our discussions
have been about potential,
reaching potential.
And in my field-- I'm a
creative person and an artist,
and we thought it might
be interesting to share
some of my process.
And hopefully it translates
to some of what you guys do.
So I wanted to
give an overview--
I don't know if
you saw the title.
But the title of my speech
was Patterns, Progression
and Ideal Creative Output.
And I'm going to touch
on all three of those.
Before I get into
my story and so on,
I want to just
touch on patterns.
Patterns can be detrimental,
and can be very effective.
We all have patterns
in our lives,
whether it's relationships,
whether it's work.
And I think it's important to
realize what our patterns are,
and it's also important
to try and expand and get
beyond those patterns.
So I'm going to touch on that.
I
You see a canvas up here.
One of my new series of works
is called the Chalkboard Series.
So I'm going to try,
while I give the speech,
to do a painting.
My version of a
chalkboard painting.
It's kind of odd
because I may have
to turn my back on
you a little bit,
and I've never actually done
a painting for an audience.
So no promises, but my hope
is to somehow include you
in the process of
creating-- in my process.
I don't know if we can do it.
We'll try, and it may
even be some interaction.
And I'll explain this
painting and so forth.
I have some notes here.
I can tell you right
now this is not
going to be formal, as
you can already tell.
I really want to just share
my experiences and my process
and hope, again
as I said, I hope
it translates, and helps you get
to this ideal creative output.
I don't know exactly
what you guys do here.
I can imagine you're
all smarter than me.
We'll will start there.
At the same time, I
think the differentiator
in all types of
occupations or skill sets
is that little extra
instinct creativity.
That's the difference.
That's probably why
you guys are here,
and not working
for a competitor.
That's probably why
Google has succeeded,
because everyone in this
room or in this building
has just another level
of differentiation.
And that comes from within.
And that's what we're after--
ideal creative output.
And how do you
get to that state?
So bear with me if I kind of
bounce around a little bit.
Before I get into, again, my
story, ideal creative output
is in sports.
As I played professional
basketball--
if what we call the zone-- it's
this place where you get to.
And you don't know
how you get there,
and you don't know
how to get back to it.
But when you're
there, it's awesome.
And in the creative world, when
I knock out a great painting--
there comes to a
point in the painting
where it can go either way.
I can lose the
training or it'd be
the best painting
I've ever done.
And right in that spot--
right in that sweet spot.
It's comparable on some
level to an orgasm.
And as we all know, you can
never have enough of those.
Unfortunately, it's
not that easy to get to
on a daily basis.
So I'd like to try
and tell you kind
of how it is that-- there's
certain things we can do
to get us to that
state, I think.
And the sports where everyone--
I know a ton of scientists.
We have one of them
here in the front row.
And they spend every day trying
to get athletes-- figuring out
a way.
How do we get these
athletes into this zone?
Well, I'm just applying that
to the creative process.
All right.
The easiest part of my
speech is talk about me.
I was a professional athlete.
I played basketball.
I was a little too short to
make the NBA, but I did well.
I played in Europe.
I grew up in Rhode Island.
I'm half Irish and half Italian.
I played in Hawaii,
and from there, I
played professional
basketball in Germany.
It didn't last that long.
I probably played six years.
My claim to fame is I
brought Dirk Nowitzki
to the United States.
I was the guy who
discovered Dirk.
I moved to New York.
I worked on Wall Street.
I was a trader.
I had no idea what I was doing.
I made a lot of money and
I lost it just as quick.
And in that process, I
was painting as a hobby.
And I realized that I wasn't
like anybody in Wall Street
and it wasn't my thing.
But I love painting,
and I love creating.
And in the process of going
broke, I painted a lot more.
And it kept me somewhat
sane, kept me out of trouble,
and I did a show.
And I sold a bunch of paintings.
And I think most of my friends
were feeling bad for me,
but I didn't care.
I said, well, I'll keep
painting until I figure out
what to do next, and
that was 14 years ago.
I still haven't figured
out what to do next.
I'm still painting.
In the process-- that
creative journey--
I somehow ended up in
the clothing business.
My designs were being used for
athletic clothing brand, which
took me four years, which I
just sold a couple months ago.
So that was an
interesting journey.
The art and the creativity
really drives my bus
and I bet you a lot
of people in this room
could say the same thing.
And now I'm here.
I'm here at Google.
And it's been an
amazing journey.
It continues.
And again, I kind of
want to get into what
it's like to have to
create something every day
and kind of trust
your instincts.
So this is where it's
going to get weird,
but we'll give it a shot.
OK the first thing
I want to talk about
is the creative process.
To me, the creative process is
very similar in whatever medium
you choose.
The first step in the creative
process is idea conception.
I'm going to give this a shot.
Let's see.
Bear with me.
Let's call it the first step.
It's going to be very abstract.
By the time we're done,
this thing will be filled.
Hopefully, if it works, it'll
all kind of makes sense.
OK, you gotta have an idea.
You gotta have a
conception-- a concept.
You've got to then be able
to execute the concept.
One thing about the
creative processes
it requires a tremendous
amount of honesty.
And as soon as you come up
with a concept and an idea,
you will quickly find out
what you're capable of doing
or what you're not
capable of doing.
There's no way
really around that.
So then you have to
really figure out
what your skill set is and
improve your skill set.
Stay with me here.
One of my skill sets
is not necessarily
giving a speech at Google.
I find that the creative
process, as I said,
it exposes your weaknesses.
And it requires you to kind
of take a step back, pull
the curtain back, and figure
out where you're not good at.
OK?
So it's important at that
point that you really
dive into practice and effort.
And at the same time,
you've got to really learn
how to use your materials.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
BRENDAN MURPHY:
Give me a question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What is it that you
have on here now for this talk?
What are your thoughts
behind all this?
BRENDAN MURPHY: OK.
You'll see some charts
and some figures, here.
These are my patterns
within this painting.
I kind of rely on certain
things in each painting.
It's kind of a trick.
It gives me
something to lean on.
I don't know where
the painting's going.
I don't know what exactly
we're going to write.
I have an idea, but I can
rely on this structure.
It's something that
I've put together.
I've done five paintings,
sorry 10 in the series.
And I've pretty much
started with the same graphs
in each one.
So this goes back to
learning my skill set.
I know I can rely on
all six of these here.
Jim gave me this
formula as an interest.
This was Sergey and Larry's
original formula for Google
when they were at Stanford.
So I thought I'd
throw that in there.
What I thought I would
do is in an effort
to ideal creative
output, I'd start there.
And I'd talk about what
are the different elements
of ideal creative output,
and then work from there.
I think, one of the things
that's important is instinct.
I think what I'm going to do for
now is get away from the cards.
I'm not doing well with it.
So I'm just going to talk.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: When
you're working, you
have good days and bad days.
BRENDAN MURPHY: I have
very low expectations,
and so I'm often surprised.
Which has worked for me.
And it's interesting
because I had
this conversation
with my best pal.
And I grew up in a working
class, blue-collar environment.
And the idea of a painter was
somebody who painted homes.
And my parents were
professors, so not in my house
but my environment
was very blue collar.
And the bar is very low.
The bar of
expectations-- basically
you were expected to get a
job and not die broke and not
be homeless.
And what I've realized with
this whole process of painting
and becoming an artist-- I've
totally thrown the bar out.
I'm making a living
making paintings.
So the idea of having any sort
of limit or expectations--
I'm basically trying,
every day when I sit down
to do a painting, I'm
throwing out any expectations.
I'm throwing out any parameters.
And I think that's a big-- you
really have to be fearless.
Why don't we just add that in?
And I put a number
in front of it
because I think it's important.
AUDIENCE: Sounds
like prism as well.
BRENDAN MURPHY:
Yeah, that's coming.
Look, I think
everyone in this room
has a certain skill set that
you've learned in school.
You guys are pretty comfortable.
You can fall back on a
certain amount of stuff.
There's probably
someone that you
work next to that's at that
next level-- something that
makes them different.
And these two elements
are a big part of that.
Somewhere along
the line, they had
to trust their instinct
for no good reason.
And that instinct, for an
artist, is all that you have.
It's the only thing that
makes you different--
is that instinct.
And I'm continually amazed
when I finish a good painting
and I'm also amazed at how
bad my paintings can be.
But it's that process of
just trusting and going
with it that's very important.
I mean, I'd like to
know a little bit more
about what you guys do,
and I'm sorry go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRENDAN MURPHY: Yeah,
there's a certain--
I produce a lot of work.
I work on a daily basis,
whether it's painting
or-- I'm creating.
I think there's a
certain point where
you have to step
away from the work.
And one of the points I
wanted to talk about today
was the tension and resolution.
This idea of tension and stress
is not necessarily a bad thing,
it's required.
And we're told too much stress
can kill you and too much
tension-- it's required.
So I think when you mention a
bad painting or something that
doesn't represent my work well,
that's part of the tension.
And then I have to step back and
say, well what did I do wrong?
What could I do better?
And I have to
improve my skill set.
And I have to practice.
Then you get into 10,000
hours, and Malcolm Gladwell,
which is a very true statement.
So I would say my success rate
at this point is probably 60%.
6 out of 10 are
decent paintings,
and four really fail.
And two of the 10 are
really exceptional.
And I'm trying to improve that.
I think when I
started it was lower.
The success rate was much lower.
You can't really
beat yourself up
too much about it, which
I think is important.
Anyways, let's talk about
tension and resolution.
I'm going to jump
around at this point.
We talk a lot about sports--
stress and recovery,
the concept of
tension a resolution.
And my pal brought
up a good point
that within the painting,
if I push the painting
to a certain spot, I get
to a spot of tension.
I don't know what to do.
And somehow I find an
answer and resolution.
And then I mess it
up again, and I'm
in this spot where I
don't know what to do.
And I resolve it again.
And every time I go
through this process,
I land a little bit higher.
I'm going to add resolution.
This is a big part
of the process.
A lot of people get
stuck in the tension.
stuck at stress.
You want to learn
how to play a song,
or you can't play a chord.
You don't learn how to play
it you never play the song.
You can't execute your idea.
Again, before-- I would like
to know a little bit more
about what you guys do.
I'd like to-- I'm thinking--
maybe your process is similar.
I don't know.
Do you mind?
What part of the
business are you in?
AUDIENCE: I work
on Google Fiber.
I'm a software engineer
on the backend side.
So anything related to--
BRENDAN MURPHY:
And you write code?
And is there a part of that
process where you get stuck,
and if so, do you--
are you alone?
Do you have a team?
AUDIENCE: So sometimes I get
stuck and in some cases I just
keep getting back
to the problem,
hitting it from
different angles,
trying to find that
way of solving.
BRENDAN MURPHY: Right.
So you keep hitting
this, step back, recover,
hit the tension again.
And at each time you
go through that process
you land a little higher
until you solve it.
And then what?
Then there's a new problem.
And this is a daily or weekly
type-- depends on the project?
AUDIENCE: Right.
BRENDAN MURPHY: OK.
So that's my painting process
in a much different environment.
It's a little bit more solitary.
As my wife can
tell you, I'm very
comfortable in the unknown.
I thrive in the unknown which I
think bids well for an artist.
Or, in trying to achieve
ideal creative output,
trying to get to that
spot, if you're not
comfortable with the unknown
you've got to get ready.
Because there's--
exactly what you said.
There's a spot where you don't
know exactly where it's going.
You have an idea,
you have a concept,
you have your skill
set, and then you begin.
And you're going to
run into some problems,
but getting through
those problems
is then-- all of a sudden
you've broken through
and you get to this next level.
And you'll never go back.
So I'm very comfortable
with that process.
I'm very comfortable
in the unknown.
And I think it's important if
you're not that type of person,
I think you have to start
to accept that that's OK.
It's OK to not know
where it's going.
It's OK to not have control.
And I think that's an inhibitor.
That's a real block,
especially in sports.
We do a lot with
tennis-- I play tennis.
And we'll be joined by one of
the best players in the world,
later today.
And he's a guy who really has--
AUDIENCE: Who's that?
BRENDAN MURPHY: Novak Djokavic
is on his way here, today.
And I don't know if you watched
the match yesterday, but here's
a guy who-- and I know
because my clothing company--
we sponsored a guy who
is 30 in the world.
And he can hit a
tennis ball as well as
anyone has ever hit a
tennis ball, as can Novak.
And we watched them practice
only a couple weeks ago.
But there was a
clear difference.
It wasn't in how
they hit the ball.
It was a difference
in instinct, and it
was different in--
Novak had just a feel.
He trusted himself
more than his opponent.
And you see it yesterday.
It is that next level that
I find-- first of all,
he's very comfortable
in that area
where ooh, this could go bad.
He thrives in that.
And I think that's
a really big deal.
And I think there's a
reason in my attempt
to-- I have so much
to share with you
guys and my attempt to
get some points across.
This is a big deal.
This was a big deal.
Eric Fishchl was
a mentor of mine.
He's one of the most famous
painters in the world.
And again, he said,
instinct is all you have.
That spot where you
get stuck, you've
got to trust what you feel
is the right direction.
You got to go with it.
And if you fail,
then do it again.
And just keep doing that.
Because if you stick
by, let's say, the book,
there's nothing
different about you
than the guy
sitting next to you.
And I think that's a
real spot where people
get stuck in terms of being
different and differentiation.
People get stuck.
They say, I'll just
fall back and I'm not
going to go the extra mile.
And I find that my best
paintings, and anything I've
done well, it's come
from like some crazy idea
that I had internally.
And then I pursued it, failed.
Pursued it, failed.
And somehow it comes together.
You have to understand,
from where I come from
and my friends have
joined, here's my wife,
my dog's even here.
This was a really-- I mean,
I've given a bunch of speeches,
and I've never had the
problems I've had today.
But I just was so
excited-- more about being
in this environment, feeling
like I have contemporaries
around me who business
understand the element of risk.
They understand the element of
tension, resolution, stress,
recovery.
And I think I got a little
bit too hopped up about it.
But it's very similar
to the creative process.
It's a very solitary
pursuit, as well,
as I'm sure a lot of
engineers would understand.
There's no way around
putting in 10,000 hours.
There's no way around it.
There's no way around working
by yourself for a long time
and working things out.
There's just no way around it.
And a lot of kids or younger
people don't really get that.
You can have talent.
You don't put the time in--
it's not going to work.
And again, if you don't
go through that process
of tension, resolution,
stress, recovery,
you're just not
going to get there.
I do want to talk
about discomfort
and the idea of
being comfortable.
That's a death blow
for creativity.
That's a death blow for success.
Once you're comfortable,
you're done.
Once you fall back on certain
patterns, you're cooked.
So I think you need to explore
ways to take yourself out
of that comfort zone.
That's a big deal.
Is there a way to do that
in software engineering?
That's interesting.
You're presenting
it as an exercise.
But it has to
become a condition.
It's not an exercise.
It's a condition.
And I bet you Sergey
and Larry, whoever
runs-- I'll bet you that's a
condition every day for them.
It's not an exercise--
I'm not passing judgement
because we come from that
space where most of us grew up
or educated under
certain parameters
where you went
through exercises.
And it's funny
because it should be
exactly how you think every day.
And what's amazing
is the quicker
you start thinking that way--
I'll give you an example.
I've used the formulas
in a lot of my paintings.
Maybe you've seen them.
And I used it.
I started using it
as almost a fallback.
When I didn't know what to
put there I'd write a formula.
I'd do a beautiful
painting of a woman
and I wouldn't know
what to put in the space
and I'd write a formula.
And to anyone who'd not seen
my paintings it's pretty cool.
There's kind of a
graffiti element to it,
but it was a real
fallback for me.
And I knew it.
So one day, early this spring,
last year, I said, that's it.
I'm never doing
another formula again.
I'm going to do one painting.
I did a huge painting
and it's only formulas
and I'm never doing
formulas again.
I'm done.
It's the only way I
can get beyond it.
Sure enough, I do it.
I put it in the show.
And I've got a surgeon,
a mathematician,
and another hedge-fund
guy and they're
battling over
owning the painting.
AUDIENCE: In Brooklyn.
BRENDAN MURPHY: In Brooklyn.
And I say, oh geez.
So since then I've done 20
paintings with only formulas,
but what was fascinating about
it was the surgeon who ended up
bidding-- [INAUDIBLE]
bought it, what it did was--
it was the first time
I was doing a painting
without an image--
without a figure.
It made me do a painting
with only formulas.
And inadvertently, it got
me out of these patterns
to where I've had to make
a painting with no paint.
Just chalk and words.
And it was an
interesting process.
Again, what I did
when I said that's it,
I'm-- I've been trying to
do that more on just a daily
basis.
That was an exercise.
I said that's it,
I'm going to try it.
That's it, see what-- so
now ever since then, I mean,
it's been a process of my own,
but it can't be an exercise.
It really has to become-- and
it sounds weird, but why not?
Why not do it?
Why not make that part of
your daily thought process?
AUDIENCE: You're
expressing, as you're
writing these formulas
out-- is it a feeling?
It is an idea?
Is it-- are you falling back
on any math that you love?
BRENDAN MURPHY:
Did you say math?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRENDAN MURPHY: No.
[LAUGHTER]
I think it's the
opposite, actually.
I think it was my-- it was kind
of my-- no, it wasn't hatred,
it was my fascination
with-- I've always
wanted to be a mathematician.
I was probably the
worst-- I'm not probably.
My high school
teachers would tell you
that I was not a mathematician.
But I love figuring things out.
And it gives me a way.
And what I wanted to
do-- and it's been hard.
But generally, when I do one
of these types of paintings,
I've got some music playing.
I'm trying to work some
things out in my head.
I've never done it
in an open forum
with some sort of structure.
And what I'm probably going
to do-- just because I want
to finish this-- you're going
to see-- I'm just going to go.
I'm just going to do it.
And I think there is a
certain process for me.
It's kept me some what
sane, on some level.
It's given me some
balance, the formulas.
This idea-- it's
somewhat poetic.
There's a way of
working some things out
in my mind in an abstract way.
And funny thing is, the guys
that have really dug the latest
series have all been
mathematicians, surgeons,
and they've put me on to
some really interesting--
the Fibonacci theory.
I've always been a fan
of the golden ratio.
I'm a big believer in patterns.
I think not only
patterns in your life,
but patterns that have existed
for years-- thousands of years
and everything.
Those patterns exist.
And to deny them or not
really get to know them
is a big issue.
And one of the elements
of my speech today
we're supposed to go through--
the importance of having
an understanding of history
of who's done what before you.
That's been a big
part of my process.
And any artist's process--
any creative person.
Who's done what before you?
How did they do it?
Because that's the only way
you're going to get your voice.
From knowing what
has been done, that's
the only way you're going to
get your own individual voice.
And that goes back to
knowing what patterns
and who did-- great
thing about Picasso
was he was the best at three
or four different mediums.
But within his Cubism
there were patterns
that existed that
he worked off of
and then he just
kind of sprinkled it.
And then he became the
best guy in Cubism.
So it's really vital that
you have an understanding
of what's been done before you.
And I think what's interesting
here is a lot of stuff that's
going on here has
never been done.
But I imagine
writing code there's
a certain-- is there
not a certain history
and patterns to
writing certain code?
I mean, you have to
start somewhere, right?
And it is interesting.
This is a new-- there's a
whole new business here.
Yeah.
No, that's where
it was really cool.
I connected with
somebody-- I've always
enjoyed connecting
with my collectors.
And it happened to be one of
the top surgeons in New York.
He's a fascinating guy--
operated on her knee.
It turned out to be this whole--
we all got to know each other.
And that was a
fascinating process,
but we definitely connected.
Here's somebody who,
by the way operated
on my wife, who believed
that the pyramids were
built by time travelers.
But you want to talk about
an exercise versus thinking
and this is-- and he's
one of the top surgeons
and he truly believes that.
And I'm not discounting--
because he gave me
real good reason
why that happened.
But this is the type
of guy-- and that's
what he saw in the painting.
And I actually-- in
that mathematical--
I had touched on the
golden ratio and this
going back mathematical
patterns, and so on.
That's what he saw in it-- he
saw that in there and I said,
yeah that's what I put in
there, Fibonacci and so on.
He just dies for the stuff.
But it's interesting.
You have this
great mind and he's
telling me that the pyramids
were built by time travelers
because there's no
way they could move
the rocks to build the pyramids.
Only people from
the future-- and he
gave this whole mathematical
equation how that can happen.
Again, I didn't really pass
judgment but it was, whoa, OK.
And then I said well, maybe
I'll explore my own limitations
intellectually.
Does that answer your
question, in a way?
It was fascinating.
AUDIENCE: What type of
music do you listen to?
BRENDAN MURPHY:
I'm an audiophile.
You name it, I listen to it.
AUDIENCE: Why don't
you listen to books?
BRENDAN MURPHY: Oh, is
that what audiophile means?
I thought that an
audiophile means I listen--
AUDIENCE: Someone who likes
music in all different types.
BRENDAN MURPHY: Yeah.
Aha!
I won that one.
I never thought I'd
win one at Google.
I got it.
No, I listen to everything.
And it's a big
part of my process.
You name it.
Depends on the mood.
Anything from folk to
rock to reggae-- whatever.
All day long.
AUDIENCE: What's the
stuff you don't listen to?
BRENDAN MURPHY: Heavy,
heavy metal I don't love.
It doesn't really
generate anything.
Why, do you listen to
music when you work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sometimes.
I like music.
I think music [INAUDIBLE].
BRENDAN MURPHY:
Music's beautiful.
We have a musician here,
one of the best around.
It's just a wonderful--
it's just another medium
but it's a wonderful medium.
There are things.
It's kind of what I
want it to-- and what
we have been talking about.
You got to get out
of your comfort zone.
That's a big deal.
You got to push
your limitations.
You got to go beyond
what you think is right,
and what feels good.
As far as getting in the
mental state or the zone,
I think you've got to have a
certain amount of presence.
We talked about the
word being present.
And I think that's a big issue.
I don't know how it
is here, but I've
had my dog for a couple
years and he likes to hunt.
We go on walks two
or three times a day.
It's changed my whole
life, strangely.
I don't use the phone--
I may use the phone,
initially-- get rid
of all my calls,
but at some point during
the walk I'm very present.
There's no more TV,
computer, phone.
And it's really made
a big difference.
It's been my recovery
time-- my resolution time.
My time to then get ready to
work through the tension again.
And I think it's very hard, now.
Because you're just surrounded
and you're always in
touch with somebody
and something.
And I don't know that
it's right or wrong,
because it's just how it is.
But, boy, since he's forced
me to step away from it--
some people use meditation, some
people do yoga, some people--
but he's really forced me.
And man, it's made
a huge difference
in the last year in every way.
And she can tell you.
We would have--
we have our issues
but when I come back
from walking the dog,
we don't have issues anymore.
And if I have issues with a
painting or anything else,
that recovery is a big deal.
And you may not
realize-- I don't know.
I imagine you're here 12
to 14 hours a day, right?
Are you?
I mean, do work here a lot?
Do you have time to recover?
Do you have time to
take a break, mentally?
There's certain warm ups and
certain things you can do.
I think to me, right now,
I think the biggest thing
for all of us in
our-- and we all
seem to be the same generation.
I think there's a lot
of clutter out there,
and a lot of distraction.
And I think that's a big--
the word being present.
Being present,
being right there,
right in the painting,
right in the problem,
I think that's a big issue.
And I think versus taking
that huge leap where
I can do anything
and risk whatever.
I think the more manageable
step is, how do I get present?
How can I get present more?
How can I be right there?
How can I write a better song?
How can I work through that
tension in that moment?
How can I treat
my family better?
How can I be-- I think
that's a bigger issue.
And I think it would produce
bigger results versus-- that's
maybe the next stage.
And there's a certain element,
also, which we haven't hit on.
This has to be fun.
It has to be-- you have
to have some passion.
If this is work, and not
effort-- I put a lot of effort
into what I do and it's
not necessary work.
But if what you're doing is
work and-- that's not good.
You've got to change that ratio.
Why don't I start putting
stuff on the board?
There's a good word.
Are you allowed to have
patience here at Google?
Does anyone have patience?
How much time do they give
you to work through things?
Is there an element of--
or are you on the clock?
AUDIENCE: It's a balance.
Those things don't always
happen and you can't always
force innovation.
But you can light a fire.
If you really want something,
you may have pushed through 20
different ways of doing
it and hope that one--
or in that process
you spark the true--
BRENDAN MURPHY: Yeah.
Deadlines is-- I don't know.
I mean, I put deadlines on
myself, but I think it's hard.
I think you gotta be
real careful with that.
You got to be real
careful with deadlines
and ideal creative output.
Yeah.
I would say for
me, personally, I
have a real master
in certain materials,
at least from the
painting and creative-- I
know what I-- I'm
good with color.
I'm good with certain--
hard to tell here,
but I'm very good with color.
I'm very good with
the materials.
And I've mastered that.
And I can tell you that I know
how to get to a certain spot
in a painting, as a
professional, very easily.
And then there'll be a
spot in that painting
where I've got to
trust my instincts.
And it can go wrong.
It can go real
wrong, but the more I
can get to a certain place
just based on my skill set
and-- I will say this.
In reference to your
question, if I'm
about to embark on a painting
that I'm not used to doing,
I'll practice on a smaller,
more cost-effective,
manageable kind of
medium to get me there,
whether it's a sketch--
I'm not a great sketch guy.
I can't draw great.
So I might practice
a certain thing
before-- because I know
once I get in that painting,
I could ruin it.
So I want to be prepared.
And I want to identify the
elements-- for instance,
I just got a new
collector-- he bought
Madonna's house--
young guy, finance guy,
bought Madonna's
house-- $20 million.
He doesn't have one
piece of art on the wall.
So I go in, I'm trying to help
him and advise him, as well.
He liked my work.
I mean, it's like an artists
dream-- just these walls
after walls and he doesn't
know much about art.
That, for me, is great.
That's my wheel house.
But at the same time it's
a showcase for my work.
It gives me a chance
to show some--
in a real, highly visible arena.
And I had to find a
painting that would work.
I found three pieces
that will work for him.
One of which, I've done--
I did a painting that's
25 feet wide-- a
flower painting.
Full color.
Always use color.
In this guy's case,
I'm going to do
a big painting of
just tone on tone.
It'd be a flower
painting with no color.
It's kind of a scary thing.
How do you paint flowers
with only grays and blacks?
So I've practiced on a
smaller one, and it worked.
So I'm just going
to now apply-- now
I just have to
paint a lot bigger,
but I practiced on
the smaller one.
I know what works
visually, aesthetically.
But that's an
example where I just
did on the smaller one
first instead of-- maybe
I should just risk it.
But I think there's a-- you
got to improve your skill set.
Very rarely.
Sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Is it a process
of give up, and then
just take another direction?
BRENDAN MURPHY:
Sometimes you lose it
and you have to start over.
I think a concept
I want to hit on,
since we kind of a more
open forum, something that's
played into-- I don't know
where I heard it or who said it,
but life is liquid.
It's not a solid.
And-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: It's kind
of like Bruce Lee.
BRENDAN MURPHY: Move like water.
Yeah.
But I mean the actual-- yeah,
that was his whole philosophy.
But the whole concept
life is liquid
and when you really
think about it-- a plus
b just does not-- it
very rarely equals c.
And as long as we keep trying
to put stuff in the box--
and I think that applies to
that creative process-- you have
to kind of get to a space we
you're moving like the stream.
You're moving liquid, not--
it's just not-- because that's
going to allow you to kind
of move left, move right,
and not get stuck anywhere.
I think that's a
big concept that-- I
think life experience
is applicable.
When they say life
experience builds character,
I'm low on character.
I've had enough of that.
But I think that some level of
execution that's-- application
that's required.
I don't know how
relevant life experience
is in the coding world.
It definitely is?
I mean, because I think
Jim's whole point today--
and I find fascinating--
was to kind of explore
what can make you guys different
than your contemporaries?
And what makes a top
engineer a top engineer?
And is there something
that I do that can--
from the creative, just purely
creative-- that can be applied?
I think that's the whole--
what we're trying to get at.
And I think it's
very fascinating.
We met with the director of
sports science at Red Bull.
They have one of the top sports
science-- believe it or not,
at Red Bull.
And he said something
fascinating to us.
He said, I've witnessed athletes
perform at incredible levels.
I've seen them do it.
I've seen them do things
that they don't even--
and they don't know how
to get back to that.
And everyone's trying to make
1%, 2% gains, and this guy,
he believes in 100% gains.
And maybe we should
start looking
at-- because he's witnessed
guys do things that
are just incredible, but then
they can't get back to it.
Which is an
interesting approach,
where maybe 1%
incremental gains-- maybe
we're looking at things wrong.
Maybe you really do--
instead of an exercise,
you shoot for the moon.
What's the downside?
You don't fall, you land.
You land back to where you
already have your base.
And I don't know.
Do they fire you, here,
if you're way wrong?
So you don't fall.
You don't fall.
You land.
It's different.
Fall means you-- right?
And landing-- you
can start again.
You can start again.
AUDIENCE: One question-- would
be a great painting versus
your own instinct--
BRENDAN MURPHY: I don't think
about anybody else, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You think about
what you think is cool.
This is what I think.
You're not thinking about
what somebody else--
BRENDAN MURPHY: No.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
people struggle with that?
BRENDAN MURPHY:
Yes, tremendously.
The difference between ideal
creative output and just
being decent, that's it.
Alberto Bertini, my friend
from Australia, big developer.
Built some of the biggest
buildings in Australia,
sold his company
for $300 million,
went off the reservation.
He's now covered
in tattoos, rings.
Bought his own island in Fiji.
We had dinner with
them last week.
The girls stepped
away-- and the guy's
completely out of his mind on
some level, super successful.
And I said, what's the one
thing that you can tell?
What's the difference?
What's been the
difference maker?
He's just an incredible guy.
And the word he used
was fearlessness.
Fearless.
Because the minute you
start thinking-- whatever
the people-- and this is
a guy who has done it.
And still does it.
And I thought that
was very interesting.
That was the one word he gave
me, was just this fearlessness.
And he said he's meeting
with the founder of Cirque du
Soleil, today.
I put them together.
Same kind of guy.
Just fearless, and it's bizarre.
Because we don't come from that.
It's not how we were raised.
We were raised to be
cautious and watch out
and it's going to hold you back
from getting to that next spot.
It just feels
really uncomfortable
but it's where you need to be.
[APPLAUSE]